[Música]
varias ciudades mexicanas fueron
escenario de manifestaciones ciudadanas
contra la reforma electoral impulsada
por el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador criticada por considerar que
reduce la capacidad Independencia y
desempeño del INE el Instituto Nacional
electoral
en El Salvador fueron trasladados los
primeros 2000 presos al denominado
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
la prisión símbolo de la lucha contra la
delincuencia y el crimen organizado en
ese país centroamericano lucha promovida
por el presidente salvadoreño nayib
bukele
Dos de cada 10 ciudadanos cubanos son
mayores de 60 años la estadística
representa un desafío para el gobierno
de La Isla debido a la poca mano de obra
joven para sostener la economía cubana y
a la carga que los adultos representan
para el sistema de salud tenemos los
detalles
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
en esta edición hacemos foco en los
principales hechos en los más destacados
en nuestro continente América vamos a
comenzar en México en donde miles de
personas protestaron en contra de la
Reforma al Instituto Nacional electoral
INE propuesta por el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador que fue aprobada
esta semana por el congreso mexicano los
manifestantes aseguran que la reforma
pone en riesgo la democracia mexicana
una versión que contrasta con la del
gobierno que asegura que la
reestructuración de este ente es urgente
para luchar contra la supuesta
corrupción Manuela Cano nos cuenta más
la cruz una marea rosada se extendió por
el Zócalo de Ciudad de México miles de
personas se movilizaron en contra de los
cambios electorales aceptados por el
congreso mexicano el miércoles la
reforma denominada como Plan B modifica
varias leyes que promueven una reducción
presupuestal del INE el Instituto
Nacional electoral pues esta es la
marcha donde cientos de miles en todo el
país representando a millones defendemos
nuestra democracia y refrendamos nuestra
confianza en el poder judicial para
echar para atrás el plan Beck según los
manifestantes las reformas ponen en
riesgo la democracia y favorecen al
partido oficialista Morena
hacen eco de la perspectiva del INE que
asegura que los cambios estipulados
debilitarían al organismo eliminando
cerca del 85% de su personal El clamor
principal en esta marcha es defender al
INE y con ello defender la transparencia
de las elecciones la perspectiva de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador es otra el
mandatario asegura que el INE respaldó
un supuesto fraude en su contra durante
sus carreras presidenciales en 2006 y
2012 en las dos ocasiones salió como
perdedor habló ha defendido la reforma
como crucial para luchar contra su
supuesta corrupción y alegando que
ahorraría 150 millones de dólares al año
la ley ha generado controversia sobre
todo uno de sus puntos que busca
permitir la transferencia de votos entre
partidos dentro de una misma coalición
Aunque este no fue aceptado por los
congresistas la oposición prometió
impugnar la reforma ante el tribunal
supremo
en El Salvador fueron trasladados los
primeros 2000 presos al denominado
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
la mega cárcel que se convirtió en el
símbolo de la lucha contra la
delincuencia del crimen organizado que
es promovida por el presidente nayib
bukele más detalles en el siguiente
informe de Manuel lana
es la materialización de la política
carcelaria de nayib bukele y el símbolo
de lo que ha denominado como guerra
contra el crimen en El Salvador se trata
del centro de confinamiento del
terrorismo la mega prisión que inauguró
bukele a comienzos de febrero tiene la
capacidad para 40.000 personas se
encuentra a 74 kilómetros de la capital
del país San Salvador los pabellones son
rodeados por un muro de concreto de 11
metros de altura y de 2,1 kilómetros de
largo el centro ha sido ensalzado como
uno de los principales logros de su
administración una que ha defendido como
parte fundamental de su lucha contra la
delincuencia esta comenzó su ascenso
desde que el congreso controlado por
fuerzas oficialistas aceptó decretar el
estado de excepción en El Salvador en
marzo 2022 la medida se ha prorrogado en
11 ocasiones y le otorga unas facultades
extraordinarias al presidente del país
según cifras del gobierno se han
arrestado 64 mil presuntos criminales
pertenecientes sobre todo a las maras
salvatrucha y 18 una política defendida
por bukele incluso frente a la ONU El
Salvador ha pasado de ser el país más
peligroso del mundo
literalmente el país más peligroso del
mundo
a estar en camino a ser el país más
seguro de América organizaciones
protectoras de derechos humanos han
alzado sus voces en contra de los
procedimientos del gobierno salvadoreño
cómo lo muestra un informe de Human
right watch publicado en diciembre del
año pasado el informe documenta
detenciones arbitrarias masivas torturas
y otras formas de maltrato contra
personas detenidas desapariciones
forzadas muertes bajo custodia y
procesos penales abusivos a pesar de lo
polémico de las medidas estas siguen
siendo defendidas por una buena parte de
la población bukele terminó 2022 con una
aprobación de más del 87% en Cuba el
envejecimiento de la población se ha
vuelto un desafío para el gobierno al
menos dos de cada diez cubanos son
mayores de 60 años el bajo por de
población joven en la isla se debe a los
diferentes éxodos masivos de ciudadanos
en las últimas décadas la actual crisis
económica ha provocado un Éxodo sin
precedentes lo que ha afectado la
capacidad productiva del país y también
la carga prestacional al sistema social
que garantiza el servicio de salud
mientras Cuba vive una de sus mayores
crisis económicas también se enfrenta al
preocupante envejecimiento de su
población es el país más envejecido de
América Latina y del Caribe con dos de
cada diez cubanos de al menos 60 años de
edad se explica en parte por el Éxodo
masivo de la población desgraciadamente
y vuelvo a repetir si son jóvenes por
supuesto lo que los que hacen esta tipo
de migración la situación de un avanzado
nivel de crecimiento son las migraciones
y Cuba tiene un saldo migratorio
negativo es decir emigran mucho más que
los pobladores que migran también desde
1930 Y reforzado a partir del año 59
la falta de gente joven representa un
desafío económico ya que menos personas
en edad de trabajar pueden sostener la
actividad económica del país en los
restaurantes de la capital los gerentes
lamentan la falta de
personales Y hoy por hoy en Cuba quedan
10 de los 60
es catastrófico el envejecimiento de la
población es también un desafío Social
para la isla ya que debilita el sistema
de seguridad social y salud y podría
poner en peligro a la larga la
financiación del sistema de pensiones
para responder a la situación el
gobierno incentiva a las mujeres a tener
más hijos y busca construir hogares para
ancianos Pero estas medidas sólo pueden
ir de la mano con una respuesta a la
crisis económica nos vamos ahora hasta
California en Estados Unidos en donde
unos 126.000 residentes se quedaron sin
servicio de Electricidad debido a las
históricas que han afectado esta región
del país las Nevadas han afectado la
zona montañosa de la ciudad de Los
Ángeles en donde la caída de las
temperaturas ha expuesto a los
residentes a un frío poco habitual para
California Y para esta época del año la
tormenta acumuló humedad lo que provocó
un río atmosférico moderado lo que
agravó los efectos de la ola de frío con
copiosas Nevadas
y para el cierre nos vamos hasta la
ciudad de Montreal en Canadá en donde la
concurrida calle están de mí en el
centro de esa urbe canadiense fue
convertida en una pista de esquí que ha
contado con alta aceptación por parte de
locales visitantes y curiosos veamos
cientos de personas desafiaron el frío
para asistir a esta inusual competición
en Monreal en medio de los edificios y
de los comercios el evento a Pick hizo
deslizar y saltar a esquiadores de
estilo libre más acostumbrados a bajar
pistas en las montañas
es más difícil sí que en un parque
normal pero todo es muy seguro es muy
divertido tienes espacio puedes saltarte
cosas sin hacerte daño es una
configuración realmente increíble
una felicidad compartida por el público
que descubrió las impresionantes
instalaciones elevándose en la calle
sanduni entre ellas una rampa y una
larga pista de nieve
es genial ver tú Aquí sinceramente
cuando llegué estaba mirando y realmente
no me creía que la pista de esquí
estuviera ahí la mirada y pensaba que es
esto es genial y está muy bien hecho
un acontecimiento de este tipo requiere
una logística importante ya que el
recorrido se construyó con nieve
artificial pero son esfuerzos que dieron
sus frutos por lo que el parque de nieve
urbano fue creado para reunir a la gente
y traer el espíritu de la montaña a la
ciudad el objetivo es realmente
democratizar los deportes de tabla los
deportes de invierno veamos a la vez
esquí y snowboard después de un fin de
semana de competiciones los días que
vienen serán dedicados a los aficionados
la pista permanecerá abierta al público
gratuitamente hasta el 5 de
es todo en las noticias siga con
nosotros
[Música]